hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a few weird games now you
all know what weird games are all about
they could be scary that can be funny
but all in all there's this really
really weird like this game this first
ones called verlet swing and I haven't
played the game but from what I've seen
about the game you know how spider-man
does his thing with the webs around New
York City where zip zapping around New
York City all all willy-nilly like right
well imagine he was doing that but also
tripping balls on LSD and I'm pretty
sure that's an accurate summation of
what this game is all about click to
start oh god I love it already I don't
know what the hell happened and I don't
know what's shot out of me man that was
surprisingly effective
alright level 2 ah I'm sorry wise to
move war oh wait I'm not ready hang on
wait a while I've really goofed it ah
nope no up nope ah I'm really bad at
this Oh Oh my ass oh there we go ok now
I'm getting the feel of it oh my oh it's
so cool though oh it's awesome awesome
on the music song whoops okay sorry oh
can I have a CD CD haha ok this thing
there wait I gotta get it I'm getting it
I think war do I grab on to your head
sorry sure but okay I made it doesn't oh
we good I'm so cool though I mean it's
weird as heck but it's so cool oh great
gameplay its I know you're a part of
this
oh god I don't like the way you're
staring at me oh I'm sorry
why did I do that oh sorry sorry I
didn't mean for that to happen
they tried to thread the gap I got
smashed up on your chin Oh doh oh don't
oh oh okay it's harder than I thought I
made it holy Shah thought I made it
[ __ ] right on your schnoz all right I
gotta go over it
nope nothing it under him I gotta wait
patiently ah
wait patiently but god that's ridiculous
who waits patiently in this world I am
doing loop-de-loops oh oh oh what a
saint good hand
ah come on all right come on come on
come on come on come on come on
I got your number oh I'm crying I'm
crying can you see I'll cry I am oh but
I'm a little teapot sure but I'm a
little teapot sure Wow oh my god I'm not
gonna make it
maybe I'm gonna make it I'm not gonna
make it I'm gonna make it I'm making it
I made it
okay I love it yeah I hate it I hate it
it's stupid God whose not means game
beats up I am in New York City
just gently nudged my shoulder into the
victory zone Oh
oh I really scrap oh I thought I was
gonna make it on my first truck okay hey
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine watch
this maneuver you no no no okay
dude too far too far before I get it I
have taken this too far I've taken it
too far
sorry I just went goof no pull me back
baby pull me back uh okay if that had
[ __ ] me over I would have been very
pissed oh I thought that was an eyeball
it's just a friendly CD floating in the
sky I thought it was something Oh God
not good at this
but they're just leaves that would have
been cool if I dove yeah well that would
have been cool if I would have been able
to pull that off
which I didn't whoa I did okay now you
pee ha ha IOP and AUP yes oh yeah and
get this more heads or your ago oh you
can't have not at me okay made it it's
so fun whoa where am I
I don't know but I made it okay nailed
it I did something cool for the first
time in my life I did something cool wow
you guys are proud of me right yeah
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I'm freaking out I don't know
why I'm flying I'm flying I'm getting
the hang of this thing
Oh No okay we're fine we're fine we're
fine
ha-ah gentle like a summer breeze that
doesn't look right
ha ha what is up my cranky crew huh
what is up laughs that's so cool
[Applause]
oh where am I going
oh I see oh hi this side for some reason
my wall is that how you're gonna al
okay I got time this perfectly I need
perfect timing if I [ __ ] it up even for
a moment I'll be [ __ ] what if I what
if I go here instead it seems like a
much smarter way to go oh yeah that's
that's much better hope and I'm and not
oh yes I did it okay oh that's weird
what is that a vibrant Alex rocket no my
ride this is my stop
I'm sorry please please leave it down
please ignore the fact that I thought a
rocket ship was a vibrator please cuz if
that could be written out of my history
uh God what are you doing if anything
like just please just please give me
this one thing that's all I ask
[Music]
all right nailed it I love it I love it
I love it oh my god I love it I love it
Oh huh sorry sorry man sorry man yeah
hit by the and Oh more ups more ups more
ups and the world record for the longest
time to complete a level goes to me me
please I'll take it oh if I just oh okay
oh that's
oh oh wait no this is level 16 he said
it's pretty hard though I'm pretty hard
to scoop it's where we go I don't know
what happened we oh it's not hard oh
it's hard huh no come on oh please oh
wow okay it's pretty hard
that's [ __ ] sorry it's hard hard hard
guys hang on it's hard guys did you know
that it's hard well here we go uh-huh
god it's hard oh it's so hard no one
take this out of context it's really
hard guys I don't know if I can take it
it's so hard oh god oh oh you guys got
to believe in me everybody's got to join
in on how hard this is oh it's so
[ __ ] hard oh god I'm sweating it's so
hard ah man this level it's not very big
but it's hard hang on wait this is so
hard guys there you go I keep getting
stuck in the crack it's so hard
come on please I don't want to slam my
face into the crack anymore Wow oh I
keep getting so close and they're not
finishing but it's so hard and I got an
idea what if I swing up this way to get
some speed Oh nope can't do that and
then we're up here now ah see see I
might be on to something
yeah you're game eight and you're game
no more it's my game we're playing my
game now and then we do that again I did
it I beat the system ah it was hard but
I cheated that's the life and there you
go that is verlet swing but we're not
done yet that was a goddamn delight
these games are in the description as
always so check them out if you want to
play this for yourself and I can't wait
for the full game to get released that's
fun that's fun alright
but next one is you know this Japanese
game shows where your
you know Japanese game little teapot
short and stout here is my handle here
[Laughter]
okay I'm sorry I'm sorry this is a very
serious experience you know Japanese
game shows where you uh you have to well
not you unless you've been on a Japanese
game show like this where you have to
you have to thread the needle in the
obstacle
oh I'm dead I guess I'm a skeleton
[Laughter]
[Music]
it is the blood boy oh wait I don't know
what is so he falls oh he's fine telling
me are you telling me are you telling me
[Laughter]
are you telling me that I didn't make
that one very amazing clear Oh cuz my
hands didn't make it oh that's a that's
a narrow gap huh
I'll bring the news forward for this one
I said I gotta bring the nevermind I got
it okay wait let's do it the other way
then let's bring the ankles in if we
can't bring the knees forward yeah we
got it
gotta go into a nice prayer pose
they call this Wu one upward dog and get
that head tucked down roll the back like
an airport
[Music]
and oh I'm sorry sweetie
[Laughter]
this one's easy right just kind of bring
these in and bow with respect there we
go I gotta stop twisting him
that's what's snapping the spine in half
straight down there we go just a nice
bow I'm sorry it's cuz I wasn't enough
cuz I wasn't bent at the knees they're
gonna bend at the knees there we go yeah
guys Bend slightly at the knees that'll
do it
[Laughter]
well mom tells me that's not true
I mean tells me that's very much not
true okay alright so I gotta somehow
okay what if we bring these forward
instead of back yes like a Velociraptor
here we go nope that ain't right either
okay wait gotta have me tilt forward at
just the right time okay all right
what if we're going at it backwards you
know oh it does not want to go backwards
hey Dad come on come on little baby boy
come on you you scamp there we are four
right here just please believe in me I
believe in you so why don't you believe
in me
okay fine if you're gonna be like that
okay oh you're gonna give me attitude
now well that's not right there we are
that's what I like to call correct okay
we're gonna go on some sort of a door
here we go
Lane dive yes yes yes no no yes
Oh goddamn delight oh that's not right
all right back and twist and shout nope
I would have had that if I just go the
other way I thought oh the other way the
other way yeah oh no that's that's not
right either yeah wait I'll find the
correct angle to dangle I think I think
it just fundamentally something's going
flawed with my here I am trying to over
complicate things damn good all right
yeah I'm gonna end this one here I'm
laughing too hard I'm not actually
playing the game but uh you if you want
to did you play this one you can find it
in the description below
oh man god that's funny alright alright
so welcome to breakfast at the cemetery
bone Appetit a reckless Cemetery sorry
breakfast at Cemetery not the cemetery
so this game is another skill oh hello
everyone my name is bone face great as a
skeleton it's my job to be spooky and
rattle dem bones it's a tough job as you
can imagine so I have to make sure
have a good breakfast every day so I
have enough energy a good breakfast is
essential
regrettably I struggled getting up in
the morning and often late to my job
this makes my boss very angry and that
makes me sad
that's okay though as a character in a
video game I am merely a construct and
not subject to any real feelings or
emotion don't pity me I'm already dead I
wasn't gonna I wasn't planning on a man
bone face dude bro come with me now and
assist me with my breakfast routine I
don't think I should you know what I
don't think I should I think I should
step away and never look back at this
game Oh today is Monday your calorie
target is a hundred you have 20 seconds
Oh
alrighty then alright oh oh no no no
that's not it
nom nom no ahh well this is a problem I
don't get it I don't get it
I made a bread hat my happy Bauhaus
ghost you want some Oh ghost toast I
gave a ghost some toast maybe he was
coming to steal my toast I guess my
suppose uh maybe I got a like actually
toast it no that's not right no no ha ha
well that's done same right here
ok alright seem to have discovered the
physics of this serial plane oh space to
open my gob ah I see
ah it's so clear now I see it so clearly
I have to open ah
had I known this before I would have 250
left click to start okay
Oh Oh do I have to [ __ ] I have to be
gentle with it
doink okay got it nailed that
open up oh oh oh hi oh please don't come
near me
oh please don't please don't I don't
want to there are for breakfast today's
Wednesday your calories oh no no I need
to be a polite Skellington oh [ __ ] what
happened to me oh I can't stab them well
this ain't right oh my god oh okay I
think I got it here I just know that's
not right oh stop it [ __ ] eat it well
why okay which I am very clearly trying
very hard
err okay drop in you and put it in me
there we go that's the good stuff okay
scoop a little Oh pity no scoop it'll
open a I'll take it
no not my I eat your eye
no not my eye oh oh come on this is sore
okay got one I got it you just gotta got
it
come on yes huh huh huh I'm so scared
that's so scared it's so spooky that
goddamn skeleton scared me so badly
nobody think I can do it oh okay okay
put that in my gob oh well my gob
no come back here come back here come
back here no I got to grab you
no no why why
get back here get back get nostos oh
okay uh yeah let me grab the toast first
that'd be smart
oh look how smart I am okay well that
was why was that one easier than the
other one because I had to learn the
stabbing butt kick probably no this is
not right this is not right so I'm not
right about this bone face I feel the
need the need for breakfast okay thank
you I think thank you very much today is
Friday your calorie target is okay 60 60
seconds oh no how do I there a way to
like turn this how do i there are other
buttons that I don't know there's got to
be a way to rotate it right there we go
no hang on there we go [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
Rick come on no oh oh the mouse wheel
there we go oh that's not right what the
it's not going in that doesn't make any
sense
open up your gob get the milk in alright
whatever you know what I guess that's
good enough
oh you know I'm not even gonna bother
with anything here let's just pour em
right oh yes oh that's the good stuff
oh now now we're talking about good
stuff oh [ __ ] well that's not good
all right now we're talking about good
stuff glug glug I think oh this does not
look like milk going him all right so
that didn't work or some in the bowl
quote-unquote or some milk on the blob
alright got it nailed it take this whole
bowl and just shove them in that's how
we do that's how we do that's how we do
all right
that's how why is that milk still
shooting now that doesn't make any sense
that's not how milk work that's not how
milk work give me my skele-toes you bet
god damn it what if I pour the milk in
the skele-toes you know I mean yeah
that's how we do it that's how we do it
that's that's the good stuff okay
so now they're in the skele-toes right
no cereal go God cereal okay milk that's
not right our milk time for milk
apparently and this is what milk is
doing nom nom nom
and num okay or perfect or the milk on
apparently oh no I that's happening
almost almost almost how how would
anybody I don't understand I'm real oh
okay bull I've got it oh [ __ ] out here
spoon [ __ ] off skelos poor baby poor
baby poor baby poor baby
pour the skelos drop it like it's hot
grab the mock drain up that mock soak it
in real good like oh that's the good
stuff
oh that's the good stuff get out of here
table come here baby come here table
away bleah
alright yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] no bull [ __ ]
you spoon [ __ ] yep nope I [ __ ] off don't
need you thoroughly soaked open that was
what even was that I forget the I don't
even know what the name of breakfast at
Cemetery alright so that was those three
weird games fun games but weird games
anyway hope you guys enjoyed that if you
want to play any of the games I'll put
them in the description below
links all around thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
if you've got any more suggestions for
weird games that you want me to play
no down in the comments thanks again as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]